critical race theory hurts black america
critical race theory is a cancer in our
society it is a race
obsessed world view
[Music]
can you believe it yes that's right i'm
still here living in this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bringing to you the issues and making
you aware about the violence on the
south side of chicago but also trying to
raise as much money as possible to build
a community center on a block that is
much needed a block called o-block it's
called o-block because it's named after
a young man named od perry who was shot
and killed the gangs took the o in his
name and started calling it o block we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to make it opportunity block
i'm so grateful and thankful to fox
network for giving this opportunity to
give you rooftop revelations
to share with you my thoughts my
opinions my expressions
today i want to share with you something
that has been a hot topic
around the country
i want to talk about critical race
theory
that's right
i believe that critical race theory
hurts
black america
critical race theory is a cancer in our
society it is a race
obsessed world view
over the past several years this
dangerous far-left ideology has managed
to creep into our schools
critical race theory says that america
is an escapably
racist nation
all of our institutions are based on
oppression of racial minorities
in my work as a pastor on the south side
of chicago i've seen critical race
theory in various forms taught in our
local school
and have witnessed firsthand how this
ideology hurts the black community
that's right i believe it hurts the
black community
critical race theory is based on many
lies but i want to focus
on three of those lies that are
especially damaging in the black
community the first lie is
an integral part of the ideology this
lie says that an individual's race is
his or her defining trait
nothing is more important than one's
race
race determines our position in life our
ability to achieve and how others will
treat us according to this theory
this lie distorts not only an
individual's identity but also his or
her entire ability to be
relational
christianity teaches that our most
important relationship is the one we
have with christ and that relation that
relationship comes with a proper
understanding of who we are
children of god
critical race theory only undermines and
understands relationships as defined by
race which makes a common identity such
as fellow americans and impossibility
the second lie is that there is an
enduring power struggle because most
people are racist in their core
or to their core
building a community on the south side
of chicago requires setting aside our
own biases and assumptions about other
people
black americans are
absolutely i believe hurt by an ideology
that tells them their white neighbors
are racist oppressors
forcing them to think of themselves
outside of the community
and to distrust their fellow citizens
the third big lie is
that capitalism
is a form of white supremacy
according to critical race theory
capitalism
excludes blacks
not surprisingly this lie does nothing
to encourage black views to apply
themselves or to participate in the
economy
the objective here is to clearly to stir
up marx's grievances karl marx used
class struggles to spark
enthusiasm for his call for world
communism
well-critical race theorists use race in
place of class
aiming to instill that same hatred
for free market capitalism
one of our most successful projects
has been project hood a community-based
resource center that provides job
training programs
entrepreneurships internships
mentorships counseling
homework help for students among other
services
but critical race theory teaches that
capitalism holds black people down
but the exact opposite has been our
experiences
one of our jobs program is a
construction course
participants include former gang members
and individuals who recently
are released from prison they receive
everything they need to get started even
the work boots to wear
for their own site training projects
at the end many of those
who complete the program
go on to have successful careers in the
construction field
i've seen firsthand
how rejecting the lies of critical race
theory is the beginning
of doing the transformative work
in individuals lives
we see daily the power of transformed
lives
through this jobs program
through the promise that comes from
participating in honest work
in our capitalist system
on the south side of chicago
we are empowering
and overcoming
racial divisions
teaching people to love their neighbors
regardless of race and equipping
individuals to escape poverty and crime
through
jobs programs and
other programs that are needed critical
race theory cannot accomplish any of
these things
and i believe
it only undermines our work that's the
reason why at project hood
we don't go by critical race theory
we believe
in the systems of america
and that they will work
if you work
you